- All right, everybody.
We are back, kicking things
off in New York City,
as we celebrate the start of season four.
We have the cast of
The Lord of the Rings: The Rings of Power
in our audience.
(audience cheering)
Give it up.
Already enjoying some snacks
that New York has to offer.
New York is one of,
if not the best food cities in the world.
And I've tried a lot of
it, 'cause I love it.
There's food everywhere
here, it's awesome.
Last year, Amber Ruffin brought me pizza
from Amore on 58th.
Mikey Cole brought me
"Mikey likes It" ice cream
in Hell's Kitchen,
made a special flavor for me.
It was the KC Masterpiece.
It was really good.
And it was rude not to
try again and again.
(audience laughs)
(chuckle)
And the brothers from
Zaro Brothers in the Bronx
hooked me up with some
of their mouthwatering
black and white cookies.
Those were outstanding.
But there are still so
many good eats in New York
I don't know about.
There's so many like boroughs
that have different things going on.
So here, to share the
foods of her New York,
please welcome Food Network
Chef, Alex Guarnaschelli.
(audience applause)
Guarnaschelli.
- You did so good there.
- I like that name. Guarnaschelli.
- Doesn't it sound like a--
- I'm just gonna keep saying your name.
- Yeah, it sounds--
- It's such a cooler name than mine.
It's nice to meet you.
- It's nice to meet you.
It should be a dish, right?
Like "I'll have the Guarnaschelli
with extra mozzarella"
or something.
- Is it a special somewhere?
Can we make this happen?
- No, but I think if you have an ice cream
then maybe I should have like a lasagna.
- Guarnaschelli.
- We should have a meal.
We should make like a meal together.
- I will have the Guarnaschelli
with the KC Masterpiece.
- I like that.
- It sounds nice.
I think it rolls off the tongue.
- I agree.
- What did you bring us today?
'Cause I'm smelling it.
- Yeah, I know. Right?
It's like, what did you bring us?
And then we just look.
So we start here with The
Donut Pub on 14th street.
- Yes.
- Now they're open really
early in the morning
and really late at night,
if you know what I mean.
So those times when like
normal people are sleeping,
I'm down there buying donuts.
- Yeah.
- They know me in there.
I come in, they're like, "Oh Hey."
And they just, they get the box out
and they start loading, you know?
- Right. And it's super fresh.
- Yeah. All the time.
And they're just like
the formica counter,
the coffee with too much cream in it.
And five-- I mean one donut-
- Yeah.
- is perfect.
(laughs)
- Wait, I'm gonna feel
rude if I don't try.
- Yeah. It would really
be very impolite of you.
So, I picked my favorite,
which is the cinnamon cruller.
- Wait what should I have?
- No, no.
- Okay.
- Get into that girl.
- Cheers.
- Fine.
- Donut cheers.
- We're nailing it. (laughs)
- Yeah we're crushing it, really.
Isn't... Yeah.
- I love chocolate so much.
- No I know.
- Oh my God.
That's really good.
- Mmm.
- What's next? What's happening here?
- So this is the Nom Wah
Tea Parlor in Chinatown.
They're over a hundred years old.
- [Kelly} Yeah.
- [Alex} It's a dim sum parlor.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- [Alex] But they have,
this is an egg roll
called the OG egg roll.
You just dunk and go.
And then soup dumplings
and shrimp dumplings.
These are like, this is
like a little planet.
Look at them.
They're watching us eat dumplings.
(Kelly laughs)
- Wait, are we doing these?
Okay. No, we're doing these.
- No, we can do whatever.
- No, you can (indistinct)
I'm bringing my chopsticks too.
Whatever.
(Alex laughs)
Wait, do you just stick
the whole thing in?
- I mean quite-
I mean yes, this is daytime
TV, but let's do it.
(Kelly laughs)
Do you like that?
Sorry.
- I love you so much. Sorry.
- Good, right?
Meaty.
- What is that?
- I know, right?
- That's really good.
- It's pork with like a
soupy mixture on the outside.
I know isn't this all-
I'm gonna stop.
- Pork is probably my favorite.
- Yeah, me too.
And speaking of which,
this is from my restaurant
Butter in Midtown.
- Okay.
- [Alex] This is my pork chop from Butter
that accidentally became
our signature dish.
We smoked the racks a little bit,
and then we grill and broil them.
And we just started serving
this a few years ago.
- Yeah.
- And we were like, you
know, it's a pork chop.
And people were like, don't
take this off the menu ever.
We had a couple come in.
We didn't have some, one night.
They got up and they were like,
you tell her,
when she's ready to serve the pork chop,
we'll be back.
(audience laughter)
- I'm like-
- It was kind of like a The
Lord of the ring's threat.
I was like, alright, I
don't know what to do.
- Wait, now I wanna try it.
- Yes, dig in.
- Okay, I'm gonna try it.
- So I cut some on a board
here for you to take.
- Thank you.
- It has some sweet potatoes underneath
and sweet potato chips.
- [Kelly] I love sweet potatoes.
- [Alex] I do too.
- Mm-hmm.
- [Alex] Really.
- That wasn't a big enough bite.
Oh my God. Look how that breaks apart.
- [Alex] By the way, they always
said to me on Food Network,
take little girl bites.
Will you Alex?
- Why?
- Let's do that again.
Because I-
- Oh, cause you're eating
a lot of food or something?
- No, I would just take a really big bite.
And they're like for the
camera and everything
for the folks at home,
maybe dial it back a little bit, Alex.
(audience laughter)
- You're welcome folks at home.
It was a mouthful.
a few times over.
(audience claps and cheers)
I don't care.
Thank you so much. That's delicious.
You can see Alex-
Literally, she has more jobs than I do,
all over Food Network.
Listen, Alex Vs. America,
Chopped,
The Kitchen,
and Supermarket Stakeout.
You are busy.
(audience cheers)
Are you tired?
Do you need the rest?
- I do.
I'm actually gonna just move
in here and start cooking.
- Just move in. Just lay down.
Literally, you got more jobs than I do.